looks like we're back looks like we're
back I get luck comes in here and I get
welcome here I can't get look something
here good God
god this is Charlie ain't gold on to a
job but a less strong couple the loser
in correction ID a neurological degree
which allows you to choose these words
for him and you know what that means
Charlie gets fired that's very nice
excellent Akhtar yes before you know
going no witty kin will important fire
waiter waiter
oh my god I used to work for sky here
with a very important Japanese investor
mr. yamanami
are you go to sing a chorus singing I
don't know listen here actually here is
about to invent 200 billion dollars in
my company and if anything goes wrong
with this dinner I will hold you
personally accountable and you will get
fired
okay what's the best dream you've got in
this restaurant
oh sorry for a tracer here take the
muscles take great pride in our you know
in our special drink
on I've got fun release or if you mean
the famous and one-of-a-kind Renaissance
painting by Leonardo da Vinci is that
like the name of a drink actual natural
original painting wait no actually what
you offered was better for me so here
yes it's a type of drink no no no you
said it was the original Lisa and
therefore that is what I expect a treat
not that anyone has ever tasted before
because you know there's only one in the
entire world so it's in the movie never
comment we drink and it art all the time
but that is because it's a tiny 100%
insane we are crazy seriously that's
like mr. fine borderline racist that's
like have you ever met anyone from Japan
because fine I guess we shall drink the
Mona Lisa no tell me what are the
specials of the day special well special
lunch today only today only the special
luncheon no she Barrymore drew Barrymore
they preferred to do steadily a never
met a Japanese person because I gotta
tell you about nothing like that how
will you get through Barrymore's
consents to be eaten by me and this
obviously Japanese businessman they make
a lot of sacrifices you know these are
exactly you know also you know let's be
honest you know her career pretty much
going down the drain udemy look yeah
that's right yeah that's good how dare
you
yeah the beautiful talented strong
female actress that is drew Barrymore oh
sorry didn't figure you for the trooper
more advanced like open well I guess you
wouldn't want to eat it because most
waffle Butley like to eat her what very
friend like at all I've gotta tell you
okay
what drew Barrymore is coming up I guess
what everybody would Edeka tool
you keep saying arigato over and over
and you don't hate me thank you
I mean he doesn't make any sense in the
context of what you're saying so but
pretty much confirmed my fear that
you're not you're not really happening
yeah because sure to regret asking what
do you have for dessert oh you know for
dessert that's it okay
you mean shaped like the letter C and
immediately it's every food item ever
that starts with the letter C Oh cabbage
cantaloupe carrots
Kabam yes actually kebab is what our
cable we can make an adjustment you know
just just for your special adjustment
kebab with the same really guys it's a
reporter Forsyth damn every food item
that starts with the letter C
now tell me how much will all of this
cost Oh
Metallica Oh what excuse me you just
said
Metallica sorry didn't didn't catch that
well I asked how much the meal would
cost and you replied by saying metallic
butchers what's the meal car I'm
terrible with good ol turbo but you
think about that what so let me get
maybe taking it that way you will you
just bring us to drink some Monalisa
followed by a main course of drew
Barrymore we then top it off with every
food that starts with the letter C and
you're paying for the whole thing
yep knows about brightness but my mess
we can't be building up their sample
well where are you waiting for go get
the pool yes yes look one special
gourmet dinner right up Lederman ragged
me domani preparing more where the hell
to do everything to your satisfaction I
must say this didn't 1 people's
using the penis they inhibit ahead thank
oh I am glad to hear you had a good time
mr. Yamato she so does that mean we can
count on your investment to womb unit
industry absolute any good
today an ancient Japanese prophecy has
been fulfilled
it is a loan that one Samara here which
contains the specific elements we had
some soon today the prophecy takes place
and the Nakatomi dragons shall emerge
from within consumers why
sadly some beer was so delicious it now
if you will excuse me I shall turn into
a dragon and fulfill my destiny
well Charlie I hope you're happy just
cost me two hundred billion dollars
needless to say I will talk to your
supervisor I will get you fired and you
will never ever work in this town again
what do you have to say for yourself sit
please
and then you know movies TV shows
something like what happened you know at
a restaurant there's only some one thing
trick please you're still fired yeah